qui va tout doucement comme ça le
chantier touche à sa fin l'heure est aux
finitions
voilà trois semaines que ces jeunes
volontaires restaure un ancien lavoir du
19e siècle
une première pour la plupart d'entre eux
pour les superviser une association
spécialisée dans les chantiers
internationaux
donc on avait des plantes qui
envahissait tout le sol des murs
effondrés et du coup le job des jeunes
ça a été de tout anglais voir dans quel
état étaient tous et ensuite de tout
vous construire donc les escaliers des
murs effondrés d'enlever le béton de
l'eau remplaçables à chaud
tous sont hébergés au camping municipal
du village où l'objectif est d'apprendre
la vie en communauté
au tout début j'ai fait très très timide
je voulais pas du tout leur parler et
tout ça mais au fil du fleuve à mesure
en fait
je me suis adapté allez comprendre
il ya des gens de prévisible bordeaux
d'un peu partout et moi je veux faire je
pars pas trop dans l'aude gilles tout ça
je reste un peu chez moi donc ça me fait
découvrir aussi doté de personnes
comment les gens pensent dans notre
région dans les autres pays où ça
l'association a démarché le village de
1500 habitants qui a financé 75% de
l'opération plus qu'une valorisation du
patrimoine la municipalité a souhaité
dynamiser la commune ça leur a permis
aussi de rencontrer tout le voisinage on
organisait un repas partagé
ils ont participé à deux manifestations
sur la commune donc l'idée c'était aussi
d intégrer dans notre village et dans
son fonctionnement
inauguration du site prévue ce mercredi